-Oh, you know who twatted me
last night?
-Who twatted you?
-Who twatted me on the Twitter?
Sean Hannity
is obsessed with me.
And, so last night,
he wrote another blog
about my freaking Trump mask
picture with the ketchup --
you all know the picture --
and changed my life.
Anyway, so he does another --
another blog about it.
And I wrote to him.
I said,
"I don't know if you're gonna do
very well in jail,
because someone like you --
the rate of recidivism
is going to be very high."
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Recidivism is a good thing
to knock him on. Yeah.
-It's a good word, right?
-Yeah.
-And, also, I've actually
performed in prisons,
and I'm telling you --
they would not go for Sean.
-Okay.
-Like, he's not their type.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-But he's going. He's going.
Priebus and all of them --
they're all going to jail.
-Now, so, let's talk again
about this photo.
Obviously, you know,
you have a mask, a Trump mask.
-You guys know the picture,
right?
-Yes, it's --
-Okay. All right, all right.
-It looks like you're holding up
a -- a severed head,
but no one thought
it was a real severed head.
I --
-No.
First of all, Matt Lauer of --
oh, sorry -- NBC.
[ Laughter ]
Of all people.
Right? That one.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so...
Allegedly. Allegedly.
-Allegedly.
Thank you, Kathy. Allegedly.
-Allegedly. Allegedly.
So, he calls me on my cellphone,
and I'm thinking,
"How the hell does Matt Lauer
have my cellphone?"
So, yeah,
things got so crazy that day.
I got calls from everybody.
And then, of course, you know,
someone called and said,
"What if --"
you knew who Daniel Pearl was --
so I don't mean to bring
the room down, but someone said,
"What if Daniel Pearl's mother
saw this?"
And I've performed
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
places the president
can't find on a map,
nor has he been.
[ Light laughter ]
And so, I really truly, truly
didn't think
people would make
the connection.
I just thought -- all I could
think of was everything from,
you know,
a spoof of Medusa and Perseus
to him saying famously
to Megyn Kelly --
and I'm no fan -- sorry.
But, anyway...
You know, remember that one?
"And by the way Santa Claus
is white."
Calm down, girl. You don't know.
You weren't there.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so...
I don't forget.
I don't forget a single thing.
-Yeah, no.
-I don't forget a single thing.
-Where?
-Anyway...
-Do you mean the North Pole?
Is that where --
[ Laughter ]
-No, Megyn Kelly went on --
she -- she went on a --
-I remember. I remember.
-She went on a rant
about Santa Claus being white.
And my mother loved it,
'cause, you know...
[ Laughter ]
All right, so...
By the way, it took me two hours
to convince my mother
I wasn't in ISIS that day.
I swear to God -- my mother --
she's like,
"Why did you join ISIS,
damn it?"
[ Laughter ]
"Mom, Mom.
I'm 57 years old.
I'm on the road.
I'm trying to do a tour."
"Of all the things --
I was watching my Fox News,
and they said
that ISIS is terrible."
I go, "Mom, I'm not --"
[ Laughter ]
All right, so it was as crazy --
as crazy as you would imagine.
And it got so crazy,
I really did start to think,
"I've got to make this funny."
And so someone named Jim Carrey
called me.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oooh.
-Yeah. Don't be such an [bleep]
Ooh, sell it. Sell it. Sell it.
-[ Chuckling ] Okay, sorry.
-Oh! Oh, wait.
Do it again.
-So, anyway,
Jim Carrey called me.
-[ Gasps ]
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
And the reason I bring that up
is that I don't
really even know him that well,
but it was sweet of him
to reach out.
And he said the greatest thing.
He goes,
"Kathy, you're the most famous
comedian in the world today."
And I'm sobbing,
"Oh, for the wrong reasons."
He goes, "No. Use it."
And so now I'm naming the tour,
and I'll be playing
Carnegie Hall
and Radio City Music Hall
at the Kathy Griffin "Laugh
Your Head Off" World Tour.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
I...
I do want to --
So, in no way was it
a proportional response,
but do you look --
I mean, obviously,
it was done to provoke,
and then
you successfully provoked.
Do you look back at all and say,
"Oh, gosh.
There was a better photo
to take, or not this one"?
-I wish I had, like --
Okay, so first of all,
I didn't really think about it.
And honestly,
I sent a friend of mine out
for, like, a mask
at a Halloween store for $10.
And then I got all the ketchup
because I kept thinking
about him saying at the debate,
"Blood coming out of her eye.
Out of her what --"
And I'm like,
"How many men have said that
crap to you over your life?"
So I was triggered.
I admit it triggered.
Triggered snowflake.
[ Light laughter ]
And so, I wanted to shame him.
I wanted to shame him.
He's such a misogynist, and
his policies are so disgusting.
And for the rights of women and
LGBT folks and people of color,
I was like,
"This guy's going down."
Now, granted,
it was a little soon.
[ Light laughter ]
Like, I'm just saying
a lot of people
have actually said, like,
if this had been post-Weinstein,
or post-"Me Too," maybe --
maybe it wouldn't have been
so bad.
But when you do
something like that --
I really did just try
to make a statement.
And I truly didn't think
people would think
it was an actual severed head.
Like, I'd go to a severed head
warehouse or something.
-[ Laughing ] Right, yeah.
-So, I mean --
and, also, I didn't like --
you know,
I didn't know I was just part of
the Trump, like, wood chipper.
And I should have known,
because at that time,
he had only done it to,
like, political figures.
But what he did to me --
I just want you guys to know --
it's historic.
It's never happened where a
sitting United States President
has used the power
of the Oval Office,
the first family --
oh, that group.
Let's not start with the sons,
Date Rape and Eddie Munster.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so,
I've really lightened up a lot.
-I have.
I mean they've really --
you know,
come out of your shell again.
We need to see Kathy Griffin.
-I know. I'm so shy.
All right, so...
So, you know,
and then the Fox News machine,
and TMZ was recording my tour
cancelations in real time
because of bomb threats,
which I later found out
were robocalls.
Like, I honestly didn't know
they had this apparatus
already in place.
So, they just kind of put me in,
like,
the Colin Kaepernick
wood chipper,
and they bring me up on Fox,
like,
whenever it's Mueller time.
[ Light laughter ]
You know, they bring me up.
They bring up,
you know, Maxine Waters.
Like, so I'm now just in their
group of people to go for.
-And what was -- you were doing
your show overseas.
And you were --
-Well, I wasn't.
I had --
I was driven overseas, frankly.
So, I was in the middle
of a 50-city tour.
And, you know, I just --
this is all I do, you guys.
I don't have a network
or a studio.
I go and tell my [bleep] jokes
town to town and hope you laugh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And...
[ Laughs ]
You know.
-You're like --
I've always said
you're like Johnny Appleseed
for [bleep]
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't make me emotional.
Do not make me emotional.
'Cause that was touching.
I'm only human.
And so, yeah,
I called my stand-up agent,
and I said, "This is a weird way
to route a tour,
but can you just send me
to countries
where they hate Trump?"
Two weeks later, I had
15 countries and 23 cities.
[ Laughter ]
So I -- I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was heaven. It was heaven.
-Well, I -- I certainly --
I'm -- You know,
I'm so happy
you're doing shows here again.
I look forward
to seeing how they go and...
-Me too. Seriously.
-And I'm glad to see
you're doing well,
and thanks so much
for coming back, Kathy.
It's always a pleasure.
-Well, thank you.